everyone welcome back and let's write
some more neat code today
we're given an n by n matrix so this
time it's a square matrix for sure
representing some image and we want to
rotate
that image by 90 degrees clockwise
and we are required to do this in place
so we
cannot allocate more memory we can't
just make a copy of the matrix
and rotate it like that so the challenge
here is definitely doing it in place you
can see that they had
a original matrix like this what they
did is they took
the one and put it over here
so 90 degrees basically what they did is
took this entire first
row and moved it into the rightmost
column right and so they did that by
moving this
over here moving this 2 over
here moving the 3 over here
and so the problem is when you're moving
this one over here you have to
save the three temporarily right so you
just save the three
or once you move this one over here you
can take the three
save it and move it over here and we
know that
this entire right column is going to
actually be
put in the bottom row so what is
actually going on
is this 9 is actually being moved
over here right that's where it ended up
in the result
and then this seven is being rotated
over here so that's where the seven ends
up
the one ends up over here the three ends
up over here
the nine ended up over here so these
four let's say have been rotated so
far so now we don't have to touch them
but you can see
there's a little bit left in the outer
layer so let's just worry about the
outer layer so far we don't have to
worry about the 5 but
in the result we know the 5 actually
doesn't move you know you rotate it
but what about this four now it's
basically the same
thing that we did over here right we are
rotating this
so basically we can think of it as being
in the top left right
let's the original square we were
rotating was like this
now the square we're rotating is like
this it's still technically a square
you know if you turn your head a little
bit but this is what we're doing we're
rotating this
so this 4 is of course going to be moved
over here to this two and then and
before we get rid of the two we want to
save it
and move it over here to the six
and so in the original we have a two
over here but we know
that 2 is going to be rotated right
because this is the rotation we're doing
and before we get rid of the 6 we want
to save it
in a temporary variable and move it over
here replacing the 8 but we don't want
to lose the 8 yet because it needs to be
rotated as well
it's going to be rotated over here to
this 4
and since we rotated the 2 we know
there's going to be an empty spot over
here
for the 4 to
be placed in and that's what you have
over here the four
the two got moved over here the six got
moved over here
and the eight got moved over here so
this is
still a rotation and lastly we just have
a one by one
we know that you know it can't really
rotating it will just
be the exact same so let me show you the
general algorithm to solve this problem
we're going to do this in
n square time meaning we only have to
look at each cell
in the matrix once remember the
dimensions are n by
n and we don't need any extra memory so
the memory complexity is going to be
constant we're doing this
in place in our given matrix so i like
to
set some boundaries so we know that this
is our left boundary
and this is our right boundary
initially because we're going to rotate
the outermost
layer first right the outermost square
and then we're going to move inward
right we're going to do the inside
of the matrix and the top boundary i'm
going to place
over here because that's the top
remember
the origin over here is zero by zero
this position
is three to three it goes like this
and as you go down it increases and the
bottom boundary
is going to be down here so immediately
we're gonna start the rotation now how
is the rotation gonna go well let's
start at the top left because it's the
easiest right
we know that this is the general
rotation
that's gonna take place right because
we're going clockwise
and then we're going to do that right
and we know we're going to keep
doing that with every element in the top
row so we did the first element in the
top row then we're going to rotate
the second element in the top row and
how is that going to look well
it's going to be pretty similar so since
this was the second position
in the top row we're going to move it to
the second position
in the last column right so in this
column
we're going to rotate this one to this
position
so the second to last position in the
bottom row
the main thing to notice though is that
this is offset by one
this is offset by one from the top this
is offset by one to the
from the right and so the position that
it's moved
to is also going to be offset by one
from the bottom which is where the last
rotation took place
and then this is going to be moved over
here
and so as you can see we have one last
rotation to
make right with these four
elements and they actually do form a
square
if you tilt your head enough this is a
square rotation a matrix rotation
but notice how since we already rotated
this one
we're actually not doing four rotations
for the outermost layer we're doing
four minus one rotations we're doing
three rotations
right so even though the outermost layer
was n by n we actually
did n minus 1 rotations right so we did
three rotations and let's say after we
complete
the outermost layer right let's say
we've completely rotated that
you know we had to rotate this part this
part and this part so once we do that
then we know that we actually have an
inner matrix
that we have to do so we did the
outermost layer but now we have to do
the
inside how am i going to handle that
well it can actually just be
treated as a sub problem because we know
no matter what it's going to be
a square matrix so all we really have to
do is take our pointers and then
shift all of them by one so our left
pointer will be shifted
here our right pointer will be shifted
here our top pointer
will be shifted here and our bottom
pointer will be shifted
here and so now the the last rotation
seems pretty obvious right it's so it's
going to be one rotation
it's going to include four elements and
then we will have our result
now one last thing i wanna show you and
then after that rotation has taken place
we know we can update our pointers
one more time but at this point what
we'll notice is our left
pointer is over here and our right
pointer is here we know that left should
always be less than right and
since these pointers have crossed each
other we know
that we can stop the algorithm right we
don't really have a matrix left
to rotate one last thing i want to show
you about the rotation is
we know that the five the top left is
going to be
put in this position right the 11 so
we're going to cross that out
so we're going to really replace this
with a
5 but then what happens to the original
11 that was placed here well what we can
say is oh let's move the 11
to a temporary variable and now let's
put the 11
over here so we're putting an 11 over
here now but what happened to the 16
that was over here
well we have to put that in a temporary
variable a 16
and then move that 16 over here so let's
replace this with a 16
but what happened with the 15 that was
over here well
we move that to a temporary variable and
now that temporary variable
15 is going to be placed over here
so the 15 is here and we don't have to
move the 5 to a temporary variable
because look we already put it over here
so we're needing a lot
of temporary variables i can show you a
slight
improvement to this which isn't required
or anything but i think it makes
writing the code easier so we know that
this 5 is going to be rotated
but let's do this let's do the rotation
in
reverse order so instead of removing the
5 over here
first i'm gonna take the 15 which we
know is going to be
placed over here and i'm going to put
the 15 over here
and i'm going to move the 5 to a
temporary variable
okay so are we going to move the five
over here now nope that's not what we're
going to do we're going to do this in
reverse order
so since the 15 has already been moved
let's take
this 16 and move it over here
so now let's replace this 15 with a 16.
and now we know that we need to make a
rotation from
11 to here so let's put an 11
over here and last but not least we know
that the original five had to be put
over here
and we stored that five in a temporary
variable so now let's move
that five over here and so we did the
exact same rotation
but do you notice how we did it in
reverse order right we went
counterclockwise and the thing that that
the reason that was helpful is we only
needed one temporary variable
which will make the code a little bit
easier for us but it's not actually
required
the overall complexity is still the same
the memory and the time complexity is
still the same
so now let's get into the code so the
first thing i'm going to do is set our
left and right boundaries so
left is zero right is going to be the
length number of
columns minus one but we know that the
number of columns is the same as the
number of rows so we actually don't need
this
and i'm gonna run our rotation while
left is less than right and i'm going to
go
from index so let's say we're in our top
row i'm going to iterate
through the entire row except
last element so how many rotations is
that going to be that's going to be from
left to right minus one or in
other words we can say from in range
right minus left so this is the number
that we're gonna do so if
left was zero right was three we would
do three minus zero which is going to be
three iterations even though we have
four
uh values in our first row so i also
wanna have some top and bottom pointers
and these are actually gonna be the same
as left and right so top
is gonna be the same as left and bottom
is going to be the same as right because
we do have a square matrix
it's not just a generic rectangle it's
definitely a square
and the first thing i want to do is save
the top
left value right because the way i
showed you the rotation we only need to
save
one variable so it's the top left i'm
going to
get that from our matrix so matrix of
top left and just like in the drawing
what i'm going to do is move
the bottom left into the top left
so in the position of the top left top
left i'm going to move the bottom left
into that spot the next thing i'm going
to do just like in our drawing i'm going
to move the bottom right
into the bottom left
we are doing this in reverse order
basically even though the rotation
is clockwise the direction we're going
is counterclockwise
so the bottom right is going to be moved
into the bottom left we also want to
move
the top right into the bottom
right so in the bottom right position
we're going to replace it with the top
right and the last thing we have to do
is move the top left into
the top right but remember we overwrote
the top left position but
good thing for us we saved it in a
temporary variable
in the top right we're gonna replace it
with
the top left there's just one thing we
forgot to use
so we forgot to use our i variable
so you remember how this was the first
rotation that we make
right and then we move from our top left
position we move
one spot to the right from our top
right position we move one spot down
from our bottom right position we move
one spot to the
left and from our bottom left position
we move
one spot up and then we do a rotation
from here right and then we're not done
yet from there on we move another
position to the right
another position down another position
to the left
and another position up and then we do a
rotation
from these values so
we can actually handle this pretty
easily in our code
we can use this i variable to handle
that
for us so we can add the i
value to the left index which will shift
us one
position to the right and this is also
the top left position so we're going to
add
i to this as well this is the
bottom left position and we know that
we can subtract i from the bottom which
will shift us
up by one and this is that same value so
we're gonna subtract
an i from that as well this is the
bottom right
and to shift that to the left we can
subtract
i from the right index and this is
actually this
this is also the bottom right so
we're going to subtract i from that as
well
this is the top right and as we uh
continue doing
rotations we're going to add we're going
to move down
in this column so we're going to add i
to the top
index and this is the same top right so
we're going to add an
i to this index as well so basically as
i is incremented it's going to be
handling more and more rotations it's
going to shift
these cells that we want to rotate
accordingly
and so this will basically perform
a layer of rotation so after we've
completed an entire
layer what are we going to do we
actually need to do one last computation
we need to update our pointers right
because now we're going to do the sub
matrix
so our right pointer can be decremented
by one our left pointer can be
incremented by one and that is the
entire code so
it's going to complete every single
layer once every layer has been
completed
our loop will stop and we are not
required to return anything
like it just says over here we're doing
this in place
inside of our matrix so we don't return
anything this code
is good to go and as you can see it's
pretty efficient
about as efficient as you can get for
this problem and i hope this was helpful
i hope it showed you a relatively easy
way to write this code but you also
understand what's going on if this was
helpful please like and subscribe it
supports the channel a lot and i'll
hopefully
see you pretty soon